et c'est l'heure dans ce sens public de
notre second débat des bas de société
consacré ce soir à la corrida la
proposition de loi du député aymeric
Caron a été retiré mais son combat
demeure faut-il interdire ou défendre
cette tradition des villes torrises
avant de confronter les arguments de nos
invités sur ce thème Jonathan du priez
nous emmène à Nîmes et à Raphaël les
arts avec des pros et des anticorps
même voir les veaux au beau milieu de la
Camargue une centaine d'hectares sur
lesquels pâture des bovins d'un genre
méconnus
[Musique]
c'est imposant de bête de 500 kg est un
taureau de combat
virgilal Alexandre en a fait sa
spécialité il est éleveur depuis 2009
l'autoroute de combat il se bat
naturellement avec ses congénères
il est combattant c'est taureau sont des
braves une race spécialement louée pour
son agressivité naturelle et élevé pour
la Corrida mais avant de finir dans une
arène il faut au moins quatre ans
d'élevage en plein air un processus long
et coûteux
à minima 1000 euros par an donc pour le
mena 4 ans il nous a coûté au moins 4000
euros
et ça correspond à quoi c'est frais ah
ça correspond tous les frais les frais
d'entretien ne serait-ce que de fourrage
des frais vétérinaires tous les fruits
inhérents
mais avec la proposition de loi
d'Aymeric Caron pour interdire la
corrida l'éleveur a bien cru voir son
activité mise en péril ainsi que celle
de toute la filière française composée
de 46 éleveurs mais le député a retiré
son texte avant même son examen un
soulagement pour Virgil Alexandre
quel intérêt d'élever du taureau de
combat quel intérêt
pour les faire honnêtes les regarder
grandir
abattoirs je préfère faire autre chose
moi la corrida créatrice d'emploi et de
richesse pour le territoire cet argument
est battu en brèche par les
abolitionnistes comme Didier bonnet pour
ce militant ce sont surtout les ferias
qui drainent de l'argent et non les
corridas la feria San corrida existera
toujours donne un exemple 2019 les deux
séries animent un million 600000
visiteurs toutes les corridas confondues
150 000 personnes c'est à dire qu'il y a
ami en 450 000 personnes qui sont venues
pour faire la fête aucun impact et qu'à
le maire part de 60 millions de
retombées économiques c'est la feria la
corrida n'a rien ramené il faut que les
corridas s'arrêtent on ne peut plus
torturer des bêtes pour l'amusement de
quelques personnes ça n'existe pas
si la ville de Nîmes reste attachée à la
corrida elle a largement diversifié les
activités de son amphithéâtre antique
transformer la plupart du temps ont lieu
d'événements ciel ou de concerts et la
mairie veut poursuivre en ce sens les
coeur de la ville c'est le centre de
tout ce qui se passe comme comme
activité dans ses arènes puisque d'abord
les corridas les qu'on se livre qui
amène à peu près 5000 spectateurs par an
et puis il y a des concerts l'été qui
amènent aussi
160 170 000 spectateurs tous les ans il
y a des il y a les giromes aussi qui
viennent à chaque année maintenant dans
ces arènes donc c'est un lieu de
rencontre pour les mois et pour les gens
dans l'extérieur Nîmes veut encore
améliorer l'attractivité de ces arènes
avec l'État et la région Occitanie la
ville mène d'importants travaux pour
consolider l'édifices vieux de 2000 ans
un chantier à 54 millions d'euros censés
arriver à son terme en 2034
faut-il interdire la corrida voilà le
thème de notre débat je vous présente
mes invités Laurent burgois bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes sénateur et l'air du
gars ancien adjoint à la mairie de Nîmes
adjoint la tauromachie aymeric Caron
bonsoir député à la fille de Paris
auteur de cette proposition de loi
visant à interdire la corridage
accueille également Sarah Jana bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes docteur en éthologie
on est également duplex en
visioconférence avec l'ancien ma tête
d'or Julien lescaret bonsoir bienvenue à
un avant-sortement merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation et Mathieu croissanto
évidemment est resté à mes côtés un
chiffre pour pour commencer ce sondage
pour le Journal du Dimanche daté du 17
novembre dernier 74% des Français se
disent favorables à l'interdiction de la
corrida Laurent Burgoa quel serait la
proportion dans les villes torines
est-ce que les Antilles corridas ils
sont forcément minoritaires écoutez des
sondages qui a été qui ont été réalisés
dans les villes autorides et c'est
majoritairement des gens qui sont
favorables à la corrida moi je crois que
le problème il est voilà on ne demande
pas d'exporter la corrida dans d'autres
départements où elle est elle existe de
nos jours on demande juste à la
maintenir et je crois que c'est un
principe de de respect de liberté et on
demande d'être respecté moi je comprends
ce qui n'aime pas la corrida que ce qui
n'avait pas la corrida comprenne que
d'autres peuvent aimer je me permets
allez-y parce que vous n'êtes pas
vraiment répondu à la question de Thomas
Hugues vous demandez des chiffres donc
les chiffres existent il y a des
sondages qui ont été faits donc un
sondage il faut pour aller en sortie
corrida qui dit que dans les
départements torins n'en parle des
départements 75% des personnes
interrogées sont contre la corrida et
dans les villes taurines là il y a un
sondage qui a été réalisé avant l'été et
qui dit que effectivement les gens
aiment bien la Coria mais il y a quand
même 61% des personnes interrogées qui
ne souhaitent plus qu'être mise à mort
dans la corrida voilà donc même dans les
villes Tourinnes aujourd'hui les gens
n'en veulent plus à côté monsieur Caro
on est politique on sait que des fois
les sondages sont pas toujours
véridiques et que ce que je vois c'est
que ça vous arrange mais là depuis 15
ans depuis 15 ans depuis que la
direction des sondages est toujours la
même c'est à dire que donc c'est les
sondages qui doivent faire la loi alors
je dis pas qu'il doit faire la loi je
dis que par en revanche quand il se
confirme année après année et qu'une
tendance ne cesse de grandir à un moment
peut-être quand même se demander
pourquoi les Français pensent cela
Thomas Hugues a évoqué un sondage qui
74% il y en a d'autres des sondages il y
en a un pour l'Alliance anti-corrida qui
monte à 80% de Français qui sont posés
il y en a pour la Fondation Brigitte
Bardot qui dit 87% de Français sont
posés
c'est pas c'est pas eux qui vont dans la
rue avec un petit bout de papier ce que
je veux dire par là c'est que ça fait
une quinzaine d'années que vous dites il
y a un mouvement de mouvement ce que je
vous dis Thomas hük c'est qu'il y a
uneanimité quasi uneanimité il faut
quand même tenir compte de du Français
sur 10 qui est encore pour la coïna mais
en gros il entre 8 et 9 on sait sur 10
qui aujourd'hui nous disent arrêtons
avec ça ça Raja de la parole dans un
instant mais je vois Julien les carré
qui qui veut réagir sur ce thème de de
finalement de la de la mobilisation ou
de l'approbation notamment dans les
villes torines autour de ce projet
d'interdire ou non la corrida con quel
est votre retour
en fait comme Aymeric aime beaucoup les
chiffres je me suis permis de faire
l'étude à l'envers 74% ça veut dire
qu'il y a 17 millions de Français qui
sont donc favorables à la corrida et on
a fait une médiatisation avec les toréos
récemment justement par rapport à cette
PPL et on a fait des interviews je sais
pas si je peux nommer votre confrère de
Figaro ou 300000 personnes ont votées
pour le maintien de la corrida à 64% et
un dernier chiffre la ville de Vic
faisant ça qui s'appelle la Feria du
taureau c'est 3500 habitants et les
arènes contiennent 7000 personnes c'est
plein pendant 4 jours je m'arrête là je
crois que les chiffres parlent de même
on est dans le Gers mais on va pas
continuer sur la bataille du chiffre
parce qu'il y a beaucoup de symboles
autour de ce combat et je trouve que
c'est pour ça que le débat est
intéressant ça rajana est-ce que
avec votre regard de docteur en
éthologie comment vous est-ce que vous
réussiss pas à comprendre les
afficionados les fans de corrida non moi
ça m'inquiète terriblement à vrai dire
parce que avec maintenant tous les
données de la littérature scientifique
qu'on a sur la complexité de la
cognition des des bovins et d'un grand
nombre d'animaux bien sûr qu'on sait
qu'il ressentent la douleur mais aussi
des émotions on va pas du tout vers un
respect du vivant en mettant en scène
leur souffrance donc vraiment moi je
suis très inquiète et très perplexe face
au plaisir qu'on peut prendre à voir un
animal souffrir et à montrer ça à des
mineurs qui plus est c'est vous nous
dites que la science nous éclaire de
plus en plus sur ce que ce que ville
taureau dans une corrida c'est ça la
souffrance physique la douleur ok mais
il y a aussi
pouvait en tout cas l'imaginer que que
on a besoin maintenant de donner
visiblement de chiffres pour pouvoir
l'entendre donc
justement ça ne suffit visiblement pas à
arrêter
automatiquement pourtant c'est cette
pratique que moi je juge aussi même d'un
point de vue scientifique barbares
puisque maintenant on a conscience de
ces choses-là justement mais je reprends
parce qu'effectivement ça peut ça peut
être surprenant de se dire on a besoin
des émotions que la souffrance physique
en fait la détresse émotionnelle parce
que je veux dire la souffrance des
taureaux la souffrance mentale c'est
déjà d'être sorti de sa peinture d'être
transportée dans des conditions qui sont
terribles d'arriver dans un
environnement inconnu avec des gens qui
hurlent et c'est la on en parle pas de
la peur on parle de son agressivité de
sa combativité mais c'est un animal qui
est terrifié dans cet environnement là
et qui se défend plus qu'il ne
combattent
vous parler de gens qui hurlent de gens
qui sont terrifiés est-ce que les gens
hurlent d'excitation
moi je crois que on peut parler aussi
avec son cœur
chez moi j'ai un lapin j'ai des poules
j'aime les animaux et j'aime aussi la
corrida et vous dire que le taureau il
est élevé pendant 4 ans beaucoup plus
longtemps que un bovin qui est abattu
dans un abattoir il est chéri par son
éleveur qui des fois l'éleveur il pleure
de voir son taureau donc l'émotion nous
l'avons aussi nous les affectionnades et
on a oui pleure il pleure parce que
[Musique]
s'il l'envoie pas faire une corrida dans
l'arène bah il pleura pas oui mais donc
vous préférez vous êtes
maintenir la biodiversité supprimer la
corrida monsieur carotte c'est supprimer
des hommes d'élevages
université ça fait partie des chapitres
que je veux bien
aborder parce qu'effectivement ça fait
partie des arguments Mathieu parce que
moi je vous mettais là je n'ai jamais vu
de corrida j'ai pas de position tranchée
sur ce sujet mais est-ce que mise à mort
est obligatoire ça c'est une première
question et s'il y a pas la mise à mort
du taureau et ce qui sera quand même
stressé l'animal peut-être qu'on en
parle
et ensuite on va aller vers
la mise à mort elle arrive à vraiment au
dernier à la dernière étape donc il y a
il se passe quand même de longues de
très très longues minutes où il souffre
à la fois sur le plan physique et sur le
plan mental la mise à mort c'est à la
limite la libération pour ce taux Julien
lescaret il y a un argument que vous
donnez souvent en vous et puis d'autres
anciens matador ou défenseurs de la de
la corrida c'est de dire que c'est une
race à part c'est un taureau de combat
pourquoi vous dites ça qu'est-ce qu'il y
a derrière cette cette
en effet je suis très surpris d'ailleurs
de voir que généralement les gens
parlent de notre métier ils n'ont jamais
mis de costume de lumière ils n'ont
jamais été dans un élevage j'ai eu un
débat avec Aymeric il y a pas très
longtemps je l'ai invité à venir voir un
élevage de taureaux pour voir réellement
ce que c'était cet animal et les images
que vous avez passé étaient déjà un
indicateur mais je dois préciser que
c'est un taureau qui attaque cette un
animal qui attaque et pour contrer un
petit peu ce que dit Madame on fait
aussi des tests dans les champs
directement à en pleine liberté où les
toront le choix de s'échapper il
continue à attaquer à agresser c'est une
la particularité de cet animal là et
nous on va effectivement l'affronter
parce que ça reste un animal de
consommation et donc le tuer du mieux
possible on a un carnet pour ça ça
s'octroie ça se ça se mérite ce carnet
de tuer convenablement qu'on ne peut pas
faire n'importe quoi il y a des règles
très strictes également et cette mise à
mort comme pour tous les animaux c'est
en tout cas ceux qui consomment de la
viande elle est inéluctable mais vous
semblez dire qu'on trouve des taureaux
comme ça dans la nature mais c'est une
sélection artificielle bien sûr donc
c'est une on a recherché cette
combativité elle n'est absolument pas
naturel on l'a entretenu et exactement
ça arrive dans de très très très rares
cas mais si l'animal était gracié ce qui
arrive une fois sur 1000 et ben il
servira à la reproduction parce que
justement ça aurait été celui qui a été
le plus mettons agressif le plus
combatif mais du coup ces rechercher
dans la nature ces animaux
disparaîtraient et heureusement parce
que dans un groupe un animal qui se
trouve agressif il est évincé du groupe
alors on va continuer d'en parler je
vous donnerai la parole évidemment aux
uns et aux autres on va se concentrer
maintenant sur la proposition de loi
aymeric Caron que vous aviez
déposé que vous appréciez à défendre que
vous avez commencé à défendre quand un
calmé vous pouvez nous rejoindre on a
voulu regarder précisément ce qu'il y
avait dans cette PPL dans cette
proposition de loi PPL exactement c'est
ce qu'on dit je commence à utiliser
votre jargon de journaliste Parlement
c'est très bien effectivement intéressé
à l'aspect technique de cette de cette
loi ce que vous dénoncez en clair
aymeric Caron c'est l'exception en fait
dont bénéficie la corrida car le code
pénal initialement proscrit les actes de
cruauté envers les animaux c'est
l'article
521-1 on va le voir le fait publiquement
ou non d'exercer des sévices graves ou
de commettre un mec de cruauté envers un
animal domestique ou apprivoiser ou
tenue en captivité et puni de trois ans
d'emprisonnement et de 45000 euros
d'amende le texte aggrave même les
sanctions en cas de mort de l'animal
lorsque les faits ont entraîné la mort
de l'animal les peines sont portées à 5
ans d'emprisonnement et 75000 euros
d'amende sauf que ce texte mentionne
bien une exception regardez les
dispositions du présent article ne sont
pas applicables aux courses de taureau
lorsqu'une tradition locale
ininterrompue peut être invoquée c'est
très important cette expression elle ne
soit pas non plus applicables au combat
de coq lorsque dans les localités ou une
tradition ininterrompue peut-être établi
la jurisprudence à identifier 12
départements où il existe je cite une
forte tradition taurine dixit la cour
d'appel de Toulouse en l'an 2000 dans le
midi de la France entre le pays d'Inde
et le Pays Basque les juristes ont
pointé de leur côté le flou autour de la
notion de tradition locale ininterrompue
dans votre rapport aymeric Caron vous
allez encore plus loin je vais le citer
on va le voir l'existence d'une
tradition locale d'une talons plus
permet de justifier la commission de ce
délit et emporte donc une conséquence
néfaste dans la mesure où elle confera
une tradition une valeur supérieure à la
loi l'idée de la proposition de loi est
donc simple si vous avez suivi
raisonnement vous avez compris le texte
vient un article unique de supprimer les
exceptions dont bénéficie la corrida
vous n'aviez même prévu aymericaron
d'inclure les combats de coq vient des
amendements en séance publique à cette
exemption enfin lever cette extension au
combat de coq un dernier mot pour
mentionner que les écologistes sont
également mobilier sur ce sujet depuis
l'année dernière au Sénat le sénateur
Daniel Salmon et ses collègues Verts ont
déposé un texte similaire c'était en
septembre 2021 jamais inscrit dans du
jour et avant lui barbara Pompili et
François de Rugy avait également déposé
un texte comme cela en 2013 et plus
récemment vous voyez c'était les images
qu'on vient de voir c'était Daniel
salmon qui avait effectivement déjà
essayé d'interdire la corrida pendant un
examen sur la maltraitance animale
l'amendement avait été largement rejetée
au Sénat avec un avis défavorable du
gouvernement d'Emmanuel Macron et merci
Quentin on va aborder la dimension on va
dire un peu plus politique puisque cette
proposition de loi aymeric Caron vous
l'avez finalement retiré le 24 novembre
dernier vous vous évoquez à l'époque
l'obstruction des députés hostiles
plusieurs centaines d'amendements
déposés on cette séquence
la corrida c'est un prétexte c'est un
peu un cheval de Troie pour un député
qui depuis Versailles a décidé de
uniformiser les cultures dans les
territoires aujourd'hui cela corrida
demain sera la chasse la pêche des
techniques d'élevage pourquoi pas les
langues régionales donc c'est ça qui se
joue aujourd'hui ça arriverament dans
cette émission mais c'est évidemment pas
la séquence qu'on avait prévu donc on va
retourner à l'Assemblée nationale 24
novembre pour vous entendre expliquer
pourquoi vous retirez cette proposition
de loi je vais déposer une nouvelle
proposition de loi
une loi transpartisane
qui sera inscrite à nos débats dans le
cadre d'une semaine de l'assemblée
et j'invite tous mes collègues de tous
les groupes parce que je sais que vous
êtes nombreux et nombreuses dans chaque
groupe à vouloir la fin de la corrida je
vous invite chers collègues est-ce que
nous travaillons ensemble pour avoir une
victoire collective qu'attendent de nous
tous les Français et les Français
la corrida sera bientôt abolie dans ce
pays je le promets nous le promettons
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente vous l'avez compris
madame vous avez compris pour
aujourd'hui malheureusement je suis
contraint contre un de retirer ce texte
Aymeric pourquoi vous avez changé de
stratégie et puis peut-être derrière ça
est-ce qu'il y a une majorité
transpartisable
à l'Assemblée ou plus généralement
Parlement pour porter cette proposition
artisanale parmi les députés c'est ça
qui est terrible pour l'instant ce à
quoi on a assisté c'est un véritable
déni de démocratie
je pense que l'assemblée est assez
représentative finalement de la France
sur cette question en tout cas dans les
conversations que j'ai pu avoir avec les
uns et les autres les unes et les autres
les constater que dans chaque groupe je
rencontrais pas mal de gens qui allaient
voter cette PPL il y a il y a quelques
semaines ce que ne montre pas la
séquence c'est le moment où j'indique
que au moment où je parle il y a 450
amendements qui restent encore parce
qu'à un moment il y a plus de 800
amendements qui a été déposé sous cet
article unique pour le faire il faut
savoir que cette PPL est déposée dans le
cadre une niche parlementaire qui est un
cadre très particulier puisque limité
dans le on étudie les textes de 9 heures
du matin à minuit et à minuit ça
s'arrête c'est terminé il y avait
d'autres propositions de loi de du
groupe de la nupaisse on a fait le
calcul malheureusement avec nos équipes
que avec les 450 amendements qui étaient
soustexte quand bien même on s'est
parvenu en faire tomber un certain
nombre vous pouvez pas tous les faire
tomber on devait quand même en étudier
un gros gros paquet on n'arriverait pas
à minuit donc la décision était très
très dure à prendre mais effectivement
il m'a dit on va essayer de privilégier
vous ne connaissez pas
les députés de la nups eux-mêmes
déposent parfois
la niche parlementaire c'est très
particulier en raison de ce temps
imparti on peut pas aller au delà la fi
ne pourrit pas les niches ça s'appelle
pour une niche parlementaire là les
amendements qui étaient déposés c'est du
style c'est vraiment fait pour que on ne
puisse pas aller dans les basses Patrick
Vignal pendant pour faire une piqûre
anti-douleur au taureau ça va être des
trucs sur ne pas faire de corrida si il
fait s'ils vont dépasse telle vitesse ne
pas faire de corrida si la température
exacte à tel niveau etc etc il y en a
des tas comme ça la France insoumise ce
qu'elle a fait jusqu'à présent on lui
reprochait à l'époque c'était en effet
déposer beaucoup d'amendements sur le
texte sur les retraites mais là 17 mais
mais là la volonté elle était claire
elle était inverse en réalité c'était
parce qu'à l'époque la France insoumise
considérait que le débat n'avait non
pardonnez-moi
c'est important que les Français
comprennent vraiment comment ça se passe
à l'époque la France insoumise
considérait que le débat n'avait pas eu
lieu dans la société il ralentissait
donc effectivement l'examen de la loi
pour faire en sorte que tout le monde
puisse organiser un souhaité pour
vraiment débattre de cette c'est
l'inverse c'est de dire on va faire en
sorte qu'à minuit tout le monde qui
bagage et qu'on n'est pas pareil la
corrida correctement Laurent Bogat sur
cette séquence et puis plus généralement
sur le fait que ce soit effectivement
ça ça traverse un peu les groupes
parlementaires que ce soit la somme les
au Sénat quel que soit les les couleurs
politiques il y a des pros et des
Antilles quand c'est vrai est-ce que
c'est là vous avez évalué une majorité
pro ou anticorida je pense aussi
les sénateurs ce sont des élus de
terrain de collectivités territoriales
regrette que ce débat est lieu pourquoi
est-ce qu'il y a pas de propriorité par
rapport à notre pays que de parler de la
corrida à un moment où il y a une crise
énergétique une guerre à notre porte des
problèmes d'inflation de pouvoir d'achat
excusez-moi monsieur Carole et dans
votre niche par le mentalfi beaucoup de
respect pour tous les partis politiques
mettre la Corée
la corrida je pense pas que ça soit le
sujet majeur de nos concitoyens et puis
excusez-moi mais vous dites si le jeu
parlementaire de déposer des amendements
votre groupe le fait bien sûr d'autres
textes c'était l'arroseur arrosé et je
regrette et je regrette
vous avez fait mettre ce texte en
deuxième position
il fallait jusqu'au bout
n'avez pas eu ce courage là je le
regrette si vous lis
partout même vos amis du RN puisque je
crois
ouais moi j'ai rien j'ai une ligne jaune
ne votez pas les amis de RMC peut-être
que c'est moi qui fait erreur et je m'en
excuse par avance si je me trompe il me
semble que vous avez manifesté avec le
RN quelques jours auparavant main dans
la main pour euh
manifester votre amour
il y avait déjà en marche il y avait des
gens de gauche et vous savez il y a de
qui oui il y a effectivement il y avait
Patrick Vignal encore lui pas de gauche
mais il y avait madame madame
Fayet Franco qui est de parti communiste
des maires de gauche parce que là vous
avez commis une erreur excusez-moi
vous savez vous avez blessé beaucoup de
gens dans les régions
un élu de gauche ne mets pas la corrida
vous avez beaucoup blessé de Jean de
gauche dans la région de réalisation
s'il vous plaît monsieur poisson
non pas du tout parce que Jean-Luc
Mélenchon 2017 il n'était pas du tout
pour l'interdiction de la corrida pour
pas pas du tout la preuve c'est que cinq
ans plus tard il l'a inscrit dans son
programme présidentiel j'ai retrouvé ce
qu'il disait à l'époque vous vous l'avez
lu non mais on peut le lire aussi
on va le dire au téléspectateur s'il
vous plaît donc il existe aujourd'hui un
cadre légal restrictif concernant les
corridas qui nous autorise que dans les
villes des régions où elle est une
tradition culturelles et interrompue au
regard de cette restriction géographique
quant à la légalité d'organisation de
corrida il ne serait pas légitime
d'organiser un débat parlementaire sur
ce sujet nous sommes par ailleurs que
l'assemblée à de nombreux autres sujets
à connaître enfin il est plus logique de
laisser les collectivités locales
concernait traiter de cette question
donc c'était pas une position
personnelle de lui enfin il y a pas une
saleté mais c'est très bien que vous
étiez ce passage je pense que vous
expliquer l'une des raisons pour
lesquelles j'ai rejoint Jean-Luc
Mélenchon
c'est que c'est l'un des seuls
aujourd'hui dans le paysage politique
français à être capable de se remettre
en question de se remettre en cause il
est toujours en train de s'alimenter de
lire d'essayer de comprendre ce qui se
passe autour de lui et oui à 5 ans vous
avez raison il pensait que c'était pas
utile d'aboyer la coda et aujourd'hui il
a changé d'avis et c'est intéressant
comme beaucoup de Français je vais
essayer de évoluer sur cette question
sur notre rageant mais c'est intéressant
parce que dans les arguments
dans les arguments dans les arguments
bien sûr c'était ce que vous avez du mal
avec les convaincre dans les arguments
merci Monsieur non non
parce que je vais vous redonner vous
aurez la parole et il nous reste du
temps dans les arguments de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon à l'époque on est bien
d'accord il y a ils ont dit grosso modo
il y a c'est ce que vous avez dit à
l'instant il y a des il y a des il y a
des thématiques il y a des il y a des
autres priorités vous vous dites c'est
symbolique c'est notre rapport au vivant
c'est ce qu'il y a derrière on parle de
la guerre en Ukraine on parle toute
cette violence mais cette violence qu'on
affiche en public qu'on met en scène moi
je ne la comprends pas quelqu'un qui ne
respecte pas déjà un être vivant peu
importe son espèce moi je je m'inquiète
un pour son rapport à l'être humain
aussi au sens plus large je vous le dis
et on parle là de toutes ces personnes
politiques qui ont voté pour et contre
il y a aussi des personnalités
extrêmement inspirantes comme Simone
Veil qui s'est opposé à la corrida
depuis de très très longues années qui
en parlait déjà et je trouve que c'est
important de le mentionner aussi cette
question le notre rapport au violon
c'est pour ça alors ça ça va au-delà de
la corrida mais c'est pour ça que vous
portez ce combat et bien sûr vous dites
c'est pas c'est pas un une sous question
c'est c'est ce que vous répondez
vous savez l'une des raisons pour
lesquelles nous faisons face aujourd'hui
à une crise écologique sans commune
mesure on parlait essentiellement de du
réchauffement climatique mais on
pourrait parler bien évidemment de la
disparition de la biodiversité puisque
il y a quand même la COP15 qui commence
à Montréal je pense que c'est un sujet
qui malheureusement fera pas la une et
pourtant qui est absolument essentielle
vous savez pourquoi on est joué dans une
crise écologique majeure majeure c'est
parce que pendant longtemps quand des
personnes ont essayé d'aborder ces
sujets on il y a plus important il y a
vraiment plus important vous savez et
c'est vrai que quand on se lève le matin
on se demande si on va pouvoir boucler
le moi qu'on a des problèmes de facture
on a et je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec ça mais il y a aussi des
problématiques qui se jouent à côté de
nous qui sont extrêmement importantes
pour notre avenir commun et il se trouve
que la question de la corrida bien
évidemment ça concerne 1000 animaux par
an en France c'est pas énorme ici il y a
3 millions d'animaux qui sont abattus
chaque jour dans les abattoirs en France
on pourrait considérer effectivement il
y a un sujet qui est très mineure par
rapport à l'autre mais symboliquement
c'est tellement fort si tout à coup on
admet on admet qu'il n'y a pas
d'exception en France au fait qu'il est
interdit de torturer gratuitement un
animal on admet cela et on fait un
énorme progrès moral on va continuer de
parler politique avec ce que ce qu'on
dit Emmanuel Macron mais dans une minute
je voudrais donner la parole à Julien
les carré parce que je vous voyais c'est
toujours plus compliqué quand on n'est
pas en plateau vouloir réagir sur cette
partie du débat je vous laisse la parole
bien sûr je suis pas très politique je
comprends pas grand chose à tout ce
jouer j'ai simplement constaté que
Aymeric avait abandonné et je sais pas
s'il aurait fait un très bon torero dans
l'arène mais en tout cas nous on est
allé à Paris avec les tourerons on a
rencontré beaucoup de députés et un par
un on a discuté ils se sont intéressés à
qui on était à ce qu'on faisait ils ont
compris je sais pas si on a changé leur
vote ou pas en tout cas il y a un vrai
problème de discours de dialogue on
s'est rendu compte que les gens
méconnaissent terriblement qui nous
sommes et qui nous sommes ce sont nous
sommes des animalistes nous sommes des
écologistes nous sommes l'exemple à
suivre aujourd'hui et j'avais tout à
fait dans le sens d'emering et de Madame
pardon j'ai oublié votre nom mais je
vais tout à fait dans leur sens on est
l'exemple à suivre en termes d'élevage
en termes de maintien de biodiversité en
termes de vie quotidienne et taurine et
en plus j'ai la chance d'être aussi
charcutier éleveur de cochons ibérique
c'est les mêmes méthodes on a des
hectares par cochon on a des limites on
ne peut pas élever plus que ce qui est
autorisé c'est la même chose pour les
taureaux on est un exemple pour les 3
millions d'animaux qui sont tués par
jour Mathieu pardon mais la chronique
sur Emmanuel Macron va attendre encore
quelques minutes parce que quand vous
quand vous nous dites je suis animalier
je suis écologiste ça fait réagir
évidemment à mes côtés mais à leur
donner nous les arguments que je
comprenne bien parce que j'avoue que
comme ça de prime abord j'ai du mal à
comprendre et puis ensuite
c'est très simple on élève des taureaux
c'est la première chose c'est la base
sur des terres qui ne peuvent pas mettre
construites sur des terres protégées on
protège donc tout on vous l'a dit une
race très particulière avec des animaux
migrateurs des insectes etc et on élève
ce taureau pendant 4 ans ça n'existe pas
nulle part ailleurs et je reviens sur
cette animal très spécifique il n'y a
aujourd'hui à ma connaissance en tout
cas aucune étude scientifique qui est
testée la douleur et la souffrance d'un
taureau pendant le combat ça dure un
quart d'heure 20 minutes pendant le
combat jamais ah si si justement il y
avait une étude qui a été mise de côté
qui montrait qu'il s'est créé énormément
d'endorphines et qui en est ah mais en
fait il prend du plaisir puisqu'il
sécrètent des endorphines or les
endorphines c'est ce qu'on sécrète quand
on a une douleur extrêmement intense
donc c'était en plus une aberration
totale et vous élevez rappelez-moi ces
taureaux dans quel objectif dans quel
objectif c'est taureau qui soit
s'entretuent entre eux donc ce qui est
permettait de justifier ils aiment le
combat ou alors pour être mi amor lors
dans les arènes c'est à dire que leur
vie finalement se résume à mourir soit
parce qu'ils vont s'entretuer soit
mourir dans l'arène c'est ça des
taureaux des consommations
c'est un autre combat après c'est votre
position qui respectable donc vous
n'êtes pas pour tuer un beau vin de
faire souffrir faire souffrir parce que
là on parle de souffrance il n'y a pas
de souffrance
pardonnez-moi mais là c'est il n'y a pas
de souffrance donc on vous dites
heureusement c'était cette émission est
enregistrée je pense que dans 10 20 ans
30 ans ceux qui vont nous succéder sur
cette planète enfin disons sont encore
là peut-être mais
regardons ces images et pardonnez-moi
mais ils auront un regard quand même
assez critique qui croiront pas ce
qu'ils entendent qui est des gens qui
aux affirmés en 2022 sur un plateau de
télévision que un taureau qu'on embroche
ou avec qui dans lequel on plante des
piques on plante des harpons à qui on
donne des coups d'épée à 5 6 7 reprises
qui ne souffre pas qu'ils ne sont rien
mais ils vont monsieur Caro vous dites
le harpon comme plante la pile
à la fin il y a ce qu'on appelle
[Musique]
anesthésie jusqu'à encore récemment et
on disait mais non mais pas besoin on va
les opérer sans aller saisie parce qu'il
ne ressentent pas la douleur mais
imaginez qu'elle est vraiment que vous
voyez le monde est thomashi vit dans un
monde parallèle une autre réalité c'est
à dire effectivement où l'animal ne
souffre pas lorsqu'il subit tous les
sévices vous savez vous savez qui dit
que l'animal souffre pendant une corrida
c'est le législateur
c'est inscrit dans la loi puisque s'il y
a une exception qui a été introduite
dans la loi dans l'article concernant
les sévices et les mauvais traitements
sur animaux c'est précisément pour
permettre qu'on puisse organiser le tour
des candidats malgré le fait qu'il
souffre terriblement pendant ses
épreuves avec la traduction
qui va au corrida sont pas des barbares
ces gens-là est-ce que vous êtes heureux
quand il meurt le taureau
heureux est-ce que vous prenez du
plaisir à regarder ça le thème plaisir
non mais ça fait partie ça fait partie
de notre culture si j'y vais avec
plaisir
je suis heureux d'aller voir un
spectacle un combat entre
une meurt est-ce que vous êtes heureux
mais vous voyez the stigmatiser déjà
mais rien me la corrida c'est une parce
que
c'est qu'un jour peut-être la corrida
disparaîtra mais laissez-la disparaître
pas besoin d'imposer alors une loi
stigmatiser pourquoi aussi stigmatiser
tous de départements
c'est grave c'est votre point de vue
mais comprenez qu'un autre point de vue
pardon je vais parler un peu plus fort
pour pouvoir calmer le jeu merci aymeric
Caron et je vais redonner la parole à
Julien les carrés peut-être parce que la
question posée Mathieu croissant d'eau
sur la mise à mort elle est elle est
importante il y a évidemment le symbole
il y a le bon je ne mésestime pas le
voilà le courage que ça peut représenter
pour un matador pour un torero de se
présenter voilà dans la reine face à un
taureau loin de là j'ai assisté à
plusieurs corridas mais pourquoi la mise
à mort est importante parce que c'est
une vraie question qu'on va essayer
d'aborder nous reste une dizaine de
minutes est-ce qu'on pourrait pas
finalement garder des corridas sans mise
à mort je dis pas que c'est la solution
idéale mais voilà en deux fois la mise à
mort est importante pour vous je réponds
en deux phrases alors les corridas sans
mise à mort ça existe c'est d'autres
pratiques c'est la culture du taureau
avec les courses landais les courses
camarguaises etc c'est une autre
pratique où il y a au bout effectivement
la mise à mort parce que c'est un animal
de consommation et qu'un boucher va
traiter la viande et la consommer et la
viande et la pardon et la vendre et je
réagis très rapidement sur ce qui a été
dit au niveau de la douleur et de la
souffrance moi j'ai pris un coup de
corps mais par un taureau au moment de
la mise à mort quand je lui ai donné
cette ce geste de les stocka il y a pas
plus symbolique j'ai pris un coup de
corne dans la jambe on a failli
m'amputer j'ai eu aucune douleur aucune
souffrance sauf quand trois jours après
on m'a dit peut-être qu'on va t'enculer
la jambe et que tu ne pourras plutôt ré
c'est exactement le même mécanisme pour
le taureau et accepter de le constater
parce que c'est mon métier je le vis au
quotidien je vais pas relancer le débat
sur la douleur on l'a déjà évoqué pardon
mais mais vous avez pas tout à fait
répondu à ma question là la symbolique
de la mise à mort qu'est-ce qu'elle
représente puisque vous vous dites j'ai
lu plusieurs de vos interviews que
finalement la la corrida ou la
tauromachie c'est une forme d'art
pourquoi la mise à mort serait si
importante
alors tout simplement parce que c'est
une finalité d'abord et que il faut bien
tuer les animaux pour pouvoir les
consommer moi je vis dans un monde où on
les mange les animaux et j'aime ça donc
effectivement si un jour on arrive dans
une société où on ne peut plus consommer
de viande et bien peut-être qu'on se
posera la question de ne plus les tuer
aujourd'hui nous la mise à mort elle est
glorifiée en tout cas c'est ce qu'on
espère donner et apporter autoroute il a
un nom il a le droit d'être applaudi une
fois qu'il est combattu et une fois
qu'il est mort également et puis c'est
aussi pas seulement l'acte de la mise à
mort ça ça dure que quelques instants
que quelques minutes mais c'est toute
une vie qui se passe autour et vous
l'avez dit avec les éleveurs avec la vie
des torero avec la culture du taureau
des millions de personnes qui vont aux
arènes et qui prennent plaisir à être
ensemble et assister à ce spectacle pas
uniquement à la mort c'est très
réducteur la mort mais c'est une
glorification de cet acte là et
j'aimerais croire que malheureusement on
pourrait peut-être un jour arriver à
tuer les animaux de cette façon là en
leur donnant autant de place autant
d'estime autant d'admiration bon on
entend ça je t'ai juste à souligner que
dans ce combat vous avez le choix vous
êtes certainement très courageux de vous
confronter à une énorme bête ça je
l'admets mais le taureau lui a-t-il le
choix en lui impose ce combat et la
plupart d'ailleurs vont essayer de fuir
et cela je sais pas ce qui j'imagine
qu'il finissent un steak bien sûr ce qui
renonce au combat mais non pas le choix
bon
pourquoi ils n'ont pas la chose
si ce qui fuit justement ceux qui sont
lâche qui ne veulent pas combattre il y
en a plein qui refusent de combattre et
ceci si on les sort de l'arène et ils
sont remplacés bah écoutez quand même ce
qui sera placé c'est les taureaux qui
boîte
excusez-moi justement je me suis
renseignée avant de venir
si vous connaissez le bien ils sont
condamnés à des bandes de Rio noir donc
je vais pas sur le sujet parce que ceux
qui veulent pas
vous connaissez pas du tout la corrida
madame on va parler un peu de politique
de nouveau Mathieu pour évoquer
finalement parce que vous disiez ça peut
mobiliser des députés dans tous les
partis politiques c'est transpartisan
mais qu'en pense le président de la
République mais la dernière fois que tu
en as parlé c'était à la veille de la
discussion prévue de la proposition de
loi à l'Assemblée c'était en marge d'une
visite au Salon des Maires de France le
chef de l'État réagit à la polémique en
deux temps on a retenu surtout la petite
phrase il ne va pas y avoir
l'interdiction demain qui entre nous
traduis curieuse ingérence même
hallucinante ingérence de l'exécutif
dans le champ du législatif absolument
pas compatible avec notre tradition de
séparation des pouvoirs mais le reste de
son commentaire était autrement plus
alambiqué je cite on doit aller vers une
conciliation un échange de là où je me
situe ce n'est pas la priorité mais il
faut que ce sujet chemine dans le
respect la considération ou encore il
faut prendre en compte les spécificités
les coutumes locales auxquelles nos sont
légitimement attachés nos compatriotes
et la condition et la sensibilité
animale qu'elle éveille en particulier
chez génération bref du charabia et en
même temps qui traduit une gêne chez le
chef de l'État donc ça veut dire que
Emmanuel Macron est opposé à
l'interdiction de la Corée en 2017 pour
le coup il avait été clair interrogé par
la Provence il répond la corrida fait
partie intégrante de la culture et de
l'économie y compris du tourisme de la
région je suis à ce titre opposé à
l'interdiction dans les territoires de
tradition taurine sont partis en marche
investira d'ailleurs une ancienne je
sais pas si auditorero torera voilà
Marie ça va dans la deuxième
circonscription du gars au cours de son
premier quinquennat les gouvernement
Philippe et Castex refuseront
d'interdire la corrida au moins de 16
ans ou même les entrées dans les écoles
Torin oui mais voilà dans le même temps
le débat sur la souffrance animale monte
dans la société et dans la classe
politique et sous l'impulsion de trois
députés de la majorité on y a fait
allusion tout à l'heure il y a une loupe
proposition de loi qui est déposée sur
la maltraitance animale et qui finit par
être adoptée en 2021 avec le soutien du
gouvernement qui a même engagé pour le
coup la procédure accélérée sur le texte
alors là on a tout interdiction des
ventes de chiens et chats dans les
animaleries renforcement des sanctions
pénales pour tous les sévices et cruauté
envers les animaux domestiques
l'interdiction des animaux sauvages
investir laissez passer dans les
delphinariums les choses sur la
zoophilie enfin il y a absolument tout
sauf sauf mais sauf quoi sauf la corrida
sauf la chasse ou encore les vaches tous
ces tous ces tous ces sujets ont été
soigneusement mis sous le tapis pour des
raisons politiques oui alors aujourd'hui
l'exécutif est partagée on le voit bien
la majorité aussi entre la peur de
passer pour d'horrible parisien couper
des territoires méprisants des
traditions ça reproche quand même
souvent adressé Emmanuel Macron
président sans racines qui n'aime pas la
France et c'est une petite musique en
temps donc ça c'est si l'interdisait et
de l'autre côté la peur de se couper
d'une grande partie de l'opinion
notamment des jeunes générations qui
disent ce que vous dites c'est à dire
que il faut respecter le vivant et qu'on
ne peut plus vivre comme on vivait il y
a une même vin ou 30 ans du coup on a
assisté à des contorsions dignes d'une
corrida ou de Danse avec les stars avec
un patron du groupe Renaissance par
exemple qui lui était personnellement
opposé à la corrida mais qui défendait
le nom texte américain ont auprès de
auprès de ses troupes bref voilà seule
chose c'est que vous l'avez je leur
avais peut-être rendu service en
retirant votre texte parce qu'on aurait
pu voir toutes ces divisions au grand
jour américain
oui j'ai durant l'objectif non j'ai dû
rendre service à quelques-uns vous avez
raison mais c'était pas possible de
gâcher le texte comme ça le texte il est
pas il n'est pas enterré loin sans faut
on est en train de travailler à la
meilleure solution pour le représenter
dans l'hémicycle le meilleur véhicule on
y réfléchi et mais là pour nous c'était
effectivement pas possible que le débat
soit tronqué caricaturé parce qu'il y
avait eu effectivement voilà on avait la
certitude que c'est repas au bout voilà
donc c'est déjà ça ça empêché toute la
possibilité et puis c'est vrai qu'en
plus il y avait eu ces signes qui
étaient très désagréables vous avez
raison de le rappeler de l'ingérence du
président qui s'est mené de cette
question on n'a pas compris pourquoi si
ce n'est qu'il y avait énormément de
pression dans les derniers jours sur les
députés Renaissance qui était prêt vous
savez que chacun va vous dire que si ma
Maya
patron des députés pendant qu'aurbergé
était absente m'avait dit très
clairement que la majorité il m'avait
dit pas de souci et macarons nos députés
vont voter ce texte oh berger avait
donné exactement le même signal à la
Fondation Brigitte Bardot
la majorité députés Renaissance vont
voter il y a eu donc énormément de
pressions qui se sont exercées dans les
semaines qui ont approché du vote
par l'entourage du président par
Dupont-Moretti qui est un ministre comme
vous le savez qui adore la corridate
pour faire en sorte que les députés
soient entravés dans leur choix bon il
nous reste moins de 5 minutes je vous
répond qu'on les consacre aux enjeux
économiques puisque c'est un autre
argument des des pro corridas avec des
retombées économiques alors il y a
d'abord cette éleveur qui nous dit ce
sont des métiers qui pourraient
disparaître Patrick alarcott qui est
éleveur de taureaux de combat on
l'écoute si demain la corrida je vais
devenir quoi moi j'ai tout sacrifié pour
ça j'ai tout sacrifié et puis il y a
tout le temps mis au top qui qui fait
partie de tout ça et là moi ils sont la
propriété j'ai des chevaux ces chevaux
là c'est des chevaux de travail c'est
des choses professionnelles c'est chaud
qu'on a dressé justement pour aborder
ces taureau pour approcher 7 euros si on
abolit la corrida tout ce savoir-faire
je dis mais il va se perdre
monter à cheval pour promener moi c'est
pas mon intérêt moi je monte à cheval
parce que j'ai un travail
si je perce le travail mais je vais être
l'homme le plus malheureux du monde bon
alors il y a une cinquantaine d'élevages
de taureaux de combat en France mais
c'est surtout Laurent burgoal avec la
question des ferias on l'a vu dans le
reportage de d'ouverture de de ce débat
si on prend l'exemple d'une ville que
vous connaissez bien donc Nîmes la Feria
de Nîmes et donc et quel lien avec les
corridas c'est qu'elle retombées
économique dans les commerçants pour les
hôtels le maire de Nîmes la reine c'est
le cœur de la cité et c'est le pour moi
de notre feria ça me fait rien à Nîmes
avec la tauromachie plus de feria ça
sera après une animation quoi je suis
désolé
amateur des informations j'ai pas de
leçons à recevoir
vos arguments pour dire 100 € machine
moi j'aimerais que dans la proposition
de loi de Monsieur Caron il pense aussi
à l'indemnisation des éleveurs des
organisations parce que ces gens là qui
travaillent pour la Corrida rien n'est
prévu donc ils se reparleront mais je
reprends la masse ça donc vous le dites
100 euros machines et feria auront moins
d'impact moins de retombées parce que
c'est le cœur de la feria les gens
viennent c'est faux mais c'est moins
finir les gens
il y a 12000 personnes dans les arènes
de Nîmes il y a plus de 120 000
personnes 150 000 dollars mais sans
corrida bon il n'y a plus d'esprit de
feria on a entendu votre argument Emery
Caron le vôtre par exemple les ferias et
en gros plus d'un million de spectateurs
on est d'accord sur trois jours oui et
combien dans les arènes sur ce 1 million
un million 200000 quand les arènes sont
pleines c'est entre 12 et 1300 donc
c'est à peu près 50000 personnes sur ces
1000000 un million 200000 qui vont aller
mais c'est quand même l'événement qui
attire le monde mais pas du tout dans
c'est entre 4 et 6% des gens qui vont au
feria et donc qui vont retrouver un
autre événement pour les experts ils
viennent pas ils viennent pour la fête
il y a dehors il peut y avoir d'autres
événements autour du taureau un taureau
qu'on ne un taureau qu'on ne torture pas
et même je pense que nous sommes
beaucoup à considérer donc vous avez vu
c'est rien du tout entre 4 et 6 %
parfois 3 % des gens qui font de la
culture taurine par exemple sans mise à
mort on peut même imaginer l'inverse
qu'il y a des gens qui aujourd'hui ne
vont pas au feria et j'en fais partie
qui ne vont pas parce qu'ils savent
qu'il va y avoir lors de ces feria à
côté d'eux des taureaux qui vont se
faire torturer et que et que mais ils
ont pas envie d'aller dans un événement
qui notamment promeut ce genre
d'événements et donc il y a des jours
moi je pense que si tout à coup on sait
que ce sont des ferias qui sont
organisés 100 euros torturés et mi amor
il y aura encore plus de gens qui
viendront faire un stigmatiser encore
déjà allez on a entendu les arguments
des uns et les autres pardon de devoir
vous interrompre mais c'est la fin de ce
débat on a essayé de le maintenir le
plus respectueux possible j'espère y
être arrivé pardon pour les moments où
c'était un peu le brouha parce que que
tout le monde parlait en même temps mais
on s'y attendait c'est un peu logique
c'est parce qu'on recherche mais
j'espère que vous avez pu voilà vous
faire vous aussi votre votre opinion et
savoir pourquoi ce débat reste important
dans notre pays merci encore je vous dis
à bientôt sur sur public c'est là votre
prochain rendez-vous politique sur notre
antenne demain matin Oriane mansigny
reçoit Clémentine Autain votre collègue
député elle écrit de scène Saint-Denis
bonne soirée à toutes et à tous
[Musique]